[MUSIC PLAYING]
LAURENCE MORONEY: So Billy,
great to have you on the show.
I mean, it's amazing some of
the stuff that we've been doing.
We've had a couple of shows
like with the AIY folks.
And now we've got the person
who's leading the whole thing.
So, can you tell us all about
it and what brought it about?
BILLY RUTLEDGE:
Yeah, absolutely.
Thanks for having me.
It's been a while
since we last chatted.
So it's good to be here
and have the opportunity
to talk about some of
the work that we're
doing with the maker community.
AIY actually started
last summer when
we were thinking about
how to better engage
the maker community with
what Google has to offer.
And I think everyone has really
heard Sundar at this point talk
about how Google is
a AI first company.
And so we felt that
getting some of the AI
that we have available, you
know, from Google Research,
and from our first party
product designs structured
in a way that could work with
makers would be a great idea.
LAURENCE MORONEY: Right.
BILLY RUTLEDGE: And so we came
up with AI combined with DIY,
do it yourself, and created
the AIY Projects Initiative.
LAURENCE MORONEY:
So can you tell us
a little about
what the AIY does,
or at least the first
releases that you've done?
BILLY RUTLEDGE: Yeah, yeah.
For sure.
So what we started with
was actually a survey
to the maker community.
So, at the beginning
of the year,
we thought, before we
jump too far into this,
maybe we should
spend a little time
and actually see
what do makers want?
And how do we engage the maker
community in the right way?
Rather than just
designing something
and throwing it out there
and seeing if it works.
LAURENCE MORONEY: OK.
BILLY RUTLEDGE: And
so, at the end of 2016,
we released our
first maker survey.
We asked some good questions
to learn more about makers.
What are the different groups?
What are the different segments
within the maker community?
As well as what is
their perception
of artificial intelligence?
And you know, is it easy to use?
Is it hard to use?
And if you had your
hands or your--
the ability to access AI,
what would you do with it?
LAURENCE MORONEY: OK.
BILLY RUTLEDGE: And we got some
really good information back.
LAURENCE MORONEY: Cool.
And then, this came
out of that, right?
BILLY RUTLEDGE: It did.
Yeah.
Looking at the survey
results, we saw probably
maybe two main groups.
One is professional and
amateur makers, mostly
engineering folks that
have a full time job,
but experiment with maker
tools and maker class hardware
on the side.
Prototyping a new
idea for a problem
they're trying to
solve or possibly
an idea for a startup company
that they would like to create
in the next few years.
As well as, you
know, students that
are learning about computer
science for the first time.
And we heard from them that
AI is sort of perceived
as hard, difficult, requires
expensive, specialized hardware
and specialized software.
And we thought right
away, well, gosh, we
want to demystify that.
Because its actually not that
hard to get started with.
And there's so much that
you can do on this you know,
affordable, capable, maker
class hardware that's available
today.
LAURENCE MORONEY:
And at Google, we
have like, a lot of cloud
services with the AI
behind them.
BILLY RUTLEDGE: A lot
of cloud services.
LAURENCE MORONEY: Like the voice
recognition and all that kind
of stuff, which naturally lends
itself to something like this.
BILLY RUTLEDGE: It does.
And that's really why
we started with voice,
is because in the last,
I would say, year or two,
I think generally
people have become
a lot more familiar with and
interested in using voice user
interfaces.
Things like Google
Home or Amazon Alexa,
or voice capabilities
in your car.
It feels more natural to
engage with computers using--
using what's built in, the
English language in this case,
rather than having to learn
approach a programming language
or work with a button interface.
And when we did survey
the makers, you know,
we clearly heard that voice
recognition and voice user
interface was one
of the top things
that they were interested in.
And so, for that reason, we
decided to start with voice.
LAURENCE MORONEY: Right.
And people were familiar with
Google Cardboard for like, VR,
right?
BILLY RUTLEDGE:
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
LAURENCE MORONEY: You went
with the cardboard metaphor.
BILLY RUTLEDGE: We did.
So we stole a page out of the
cardboard VR team's playbook.
LAURENCE MORONEY: It's
a good page to take.
BILLY RUTLEDGE: Isn't it?
It worked out quite well.
And we thought, you know, being
a part of the maker community
is not only making things
affordable and interesting,
but also just enough
scaffolding for them to learn
about the technology inside.
Because we feel
that makers would
probably you know, have
their own vision for a thing
that they're building, whether
it's a toy Tyrannosaurus
rex, or a coffee robot machine.
LAURENCE MORONEY: I'd like one
of those coffee robot machines.
BILLY RUTLEDGE: I know, right?
If we had more expensive
or sophisticated forum,
we thought that might
be a barrier to people
exploring the technology,
which is really the purpose.
LAURENCE MORONEY: I
work with a lot of kids.
And to me, always
the barrier to entry
is either complexity or cost.
BILLY RUTLEDGE: Yeah.
LAURENCE MORONEY: Right?
So it's like, you know, if
you can reduce complexity,
as this does--
BILLY RUTLEDGE: Yes.
LAURENCE MORONEY:
--instead of like,
having a, like a metal box,
and the components inside it.
And as you reduce
cost as well, it's
like, then that suddenly
makes it a whole lot easier.
And, I know you've had
overwhelming demand, right?
BILLY RUTLEDGE: We have.
Like you said, affordability
is a key factor
in doing something like this.
And again, make to our maker
survey for just a moment.
LAURENCE MORONEY: Sure.
BILLY RUTLEDGE: One of the
questions that we asked was,
what computing platform and
what programming language
do you currently use?
And you know, by far, Raspberry
Pi and Linux and Python
and JavaScript were very
popular with the maker audience.
No surprise there.
And so, right away,
we decided to work
with Raspberry Pi
for our kit here,
and possibly what's coming next.
LAURENCE MORONEY: OK.
Ooh.
BILLY RUTLEDGE:
We'll share more.
And that helped keep
the price point down.
Because most makers already
have a Raspberry Pi.
And so if we could bundle all
the accessories needed in a fun
to assemble format, such
that they could put it
together and only spend
just a few dollars,
it makes it much
more-- much easier
for them to get started with.
LAURENCE MORONEY: I mean,
for me, personally, I've
been playing with Raspberry
Pi for a couple of years.
But I just ended up
like, tinkering, just
doing some various
software stuff.
And whenever it
was to do anything
in hardware or anything
exterior, I got scared.
But this was much
more approachable.
BILLY RUTLEDGE: Yeah.
LAURENCE MORONEY: Right?
And so, apparently, they
were really popular.
BILLY RUTLEDGE: Very popular.
So, to test the
waters, you know,
we had this information
from our survey
and from talking to makers at
events, maker fairs and such.
So we knew we wanted to do
a low cost kit for makers
based on Raspberry Pi.
And focus on voice
recognition capabilities
and how to build your
own voice user interface.
We put a few ideas together.
And then we reached out the
Raspberry Pi, the foundation,
and asked Eben
Upton, the founder,
what's the best way
to get this in front
of your most interested
or passionate Raspberry Pi
hackers?
And he suggested, well, Magpie
Magazine is our monthly journal
that showcases projects that you
can do with your Raspberry Pi.
So I don't know.
Why don't we send a
few of your voice kits
out to our subscribers and
see what the appetite is?
LAURENCE MORONEY: Nice.
And that's what this is?
BILLY RUTLEDGE: It is, yeah.
So this is-- this is the--
this is the unit that we
actually ended up with.
It started off with--
LAURENCE MORONEY:
It's pretty cool.
BILLY RUTLEDGE:
We would send out
some of the PCB's
that are inside
of this to the subscribers.
But it quickly snowballed
into, why don't we
just build a kit and
brand it Magpie and Google
and put everything inside?
And that's really
where we landed.
So we structured
the kit like this,
and made it look like
the Magpie Magazine.
And inside, you know, is
the actual magazine itself,
which has, I don't know,
35 or 40 pages about
building this kit.
So it's actually the instruction
set for assembly usage
and how to hack the kit.
LAURENCE MORONEY: Oh ice.
BILLY RUTLEDGE: And
then, you know, inside
we also have the cardboard
form that you fold together.
So this is really fun to
fold and snap into place.
Yeah.
LAURENCE MORONEY: That's
before, this is after.
BILLY RUTLEDGE: That's after.
And then, the PCB's
that go along with it.
This is the hat--
voice hat, which has a
microphone and amplifier audio
output.
And then the actual
microphone is
separate with an extension
cable that goes back
to the voice hat, as well as
the speaker and the activation
button.
And just an interesting thing.
The microphone
board, we actually
made it a separate board which
attaches back to the main hat.
Because we felt
makers, as they're
exploring creative forms
with what they're doing,
may want to place the microphone
in an interesting place.
Like, maybe in the head of
that tyrannosaurus rex form,
or in the front of
that coffee robot.
LAURENCE MORONEY: Nice.
BILLY RUTLEDGE: Rather than
have the whole computing
platform, you know, stuck
to that side of their--
LAURENCE MORONEY: So a lot of
thought has gone into this?
BILLY RUTLEDGE: Yeah.
The more we got started with
it, the more involved we became.
And we really wanted
to put together
a kit that has good
value for the price.
And it prompts people to
explore their inner creativity
about what they would make
with a voice user interface.
LAURENCE MORONEY: And
I know you've worked
a lot with people in education.
BILLY RUTLEDGE: Well we have.
And I guess it should
be no surprise.
But, we started
out really trying
to get Google artificial
intelligence in front of this,
you know, amateur and
professional maker audiences
I described before.
But as the kits
went out, you know,
more and more demand of,
hey, I'd like to get one too.
And eventually, Raspberry
Pi or the Magpie
put them up on their
website for sale,
and they sold out right away.
But what we found was, so
many teachers and school club
organizers saw the kit and
felt it would be a great way
to introduce their students
to computer science,
connected devices,
artificial intelligence.
And so, yeah, a lot of
demand from schools in order
to get that started
with Raspberry Pi.
LAURENCE MORONEY: When you
first told me about this,
I said, I need to
put that to the test.
BILLY RUTLEDGE: Yeah.
LAURENCE MORONEY:
You know, just see
what it be like before we
shoot something like this.
So, to put it to
the test, we gave it
to some high school
students to see
what they would build with it.
BILLY RUTLEDGE: Right.
LAURENCE MORONEY: They
built some amazing things.
Shall we take a look?
BILLY RUTLEDGE: Yeah,
let's have a look.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
- Cool.
- We can also tell
him to turn left.
Turn left.
- Nice.
- Stop.
- Pawn to D5.
- D5 makes D5 your move.
- Yup.
And just takes,
and then you go on.
- Shop for a New
York Mets jersey.
Now she's done.
- Candies.
- Giving you two candies.
- So we get plural as well.
Nice.
Red is my favorite, so I'm
glad I got a couple of reds.
[END PLAYBACK]
What struck me about that
was like, how some of them
were so inventive with
external hardware.
BILLY RUTLEDGE: Yeah.
LAURENCE MORONEY: Right?
So I thought like, with only
five days to work, with right?
They might hack some
Python scripts together
and stuff like that.
And some of them did.
And it was really impressive.
BILLY RUTLEDGE: Sure.
Yeah.
LAURENCE MORONEY: But
there was like that one--
that one team that they
built that little hexapod.
BILLY RUTLEDGE: Yeah.
That little spider
that's crawling around.
Amazing, isn't it?
Very cool.
LAURENCE MORONEY: So it's like,
they took three server motors,
and then they had like a
little Bluetooth circuit.
And then they used this
to do voice recognition.
BILLY RUTLEDGE:
For voice control
the motion of the robot.
Yeah.
LAURENCE MORONEY: And then
because the Raspberry Pi
and the image,
the AIY image, had
like, the Bluetooth
drivers on it, they
were able to just send
Bluetooth commands over.
And the effect of that was--
BILLY RUTLEDGE: Wow.
I'm glad to hear it was easy
for them to get started.
LAURENCE MORONEY:
I didn't believe
they would be able
to do it so quickly.
BILLY RUTLEDGE: Yeah.
Five days, you said?
LAURENCE MORONEY:
Yeah, five days.
BILLY RUTLEDGE: Amazing.
LAURENCE MORONEY:
It was really cool.
And then part of
the other feedback
that I thought was really
neat was around Python.
Because some of these kids
had never used Python before.
And so it was a pretty
good choice for--
BILLY RUTLEDGE: To
get them started
with Python programming.
LAURENCE MORONEY: Yeah.
And it's-- by open
sourcing everything,
and it's on your website, right?
And your website is--
BILLY RUTLEDGE: Yeah,
AIYprojects.withGoogle.com.
LAURENCE MORONEY: And we've put
a link to it in the description
down here.
BILLY RUTLEDGE: OK.
LAURENCE MORONEY: Now,
in order to work, like,
does all this need to be
connected to the cloud?
BILLY RUTLEDGE: Well the default
use case is cloud connected.
And we demonstrate how to
use the Google Assistant
STK for that-- you know, how
to interact with Google, Google
Home kind of functionality.
And then also, we show you how
to connect to the Google Cloud
Speech API, which is a
more sophisticated voice
recognition, natural
language processing library,
80 different languages, hands on
jargon, and that sort of thing.
But no.
We also include-- or
will soon include--
the way to do it on device,
using a TensorFlow model that
can run on the Raspberry Pi.
So you can do the
cloud connected case,
as well as the offline case.
LAURENCE MORONEY: OK.
So even like, a small,
inexpensive computer
like Raspberry Pi, we've got
TensorFlow speech recognition?
BILLY RUTLEDGE: That's right.
Well, we'll have it soon.
We're just a few
weeks away from making
that available as a
release on the website.
LAURENCE MORONEY:
That's exciting.
BILLY RUTLEDGE: So yes.
We intended to include
it with the launch.
But we were a little
bit slow gathering
the training data needed
to craft that model
and make it available.
LAURENCE MORONEY: I saw
there was like a link.
Went out a couple
weeks ago, right?
BILLY RUTLEDGE: Yeah, yeah.
That's right.
So, there's a link
on the website,
AIYprojects.with
Google.com/voice.
LAURENCE MORONEY: OK.
BILLY RUTLEDGE: And if you
can look on the left nav,
under the maker's
guide, there is a link
to understand how
to do it on device.
Which, right now, there's
just a simple step
to submit your speech
so we can capture
people saying the
words that we want
to put into the vocabulary.
And I think, for now, we're
looking at simple transport
type of controls, words like,
stop, go, left, right, up,
down.
Things that you might
tell a device to
do to command to
take some action.
And once we have enough data
coming through that channel,
we'll begin training the model.
And then release,
not only the model,
so that you can run it inside
of the kit offline, but also,
release the training data.
So, you know, the spirit
of AIY is very open,
open source, freely
available, low cost,
when you have to
include the accessories.
And so we want to make sure that
the data that we're gathering
through the website
to train the models
is also freely
available for everyone
to take, and maybe
create their own models,
if that's what interests you.
LAURENCE MORONEY:
So the more people
that do that, to train it, the
better the models' going to be.
BILLY RUTLEDGE:
The better it gets.
Yeah.
The higher accuracy,
the better response.
LAURENCE MORONEY: Because I
responded to that when it first
came out.
And I sent my voice in.
And I just hope lots
of other people do it.
Or this is only going to be
able to recognize Irish accents.
BILLY RUTLEDGE: I did as well.
That's funny.
I did as well.
And I've just been looking
at them coming through.
And we're having
quite a good response.
So thanks for everyone
that's done that.
And let's keep them coming in.
LAURENCE MORONEY:
Keep them coming.
And we'll put the link in the
description below this video,
right down here.
BILLY RUTLEDGE: Perfect.
Great.
LAURENCE MORONEY:
So, given that this
has been so popular,
where do you think you're
going to go next with it?
BILLY RUTLEDGE: Well, I
think the general direction
that we're going next
is to bring more--
more ways for people
to create interfaces
for computers that are natural.
So, if this is using your voice
to communicate with a computer,
what are the other ways
that human naturally
communicate between themselves?
Like you and I are interacting
through voice or ears or eyes
and hand gestures.
So, looking at a way to
bring those technologies
into low cost, affordable
kits for people to explore.
Maybe mix and match and build
more interesting things with--
this is kind of the
direction that we hope
to go this year and next year.
LAURENCE MORONEY:
And me personally,
I've been like,
tinkering with the maker
space for a little while.
But having something
that easily expands
the boundaries of what I
can do in the maker space
is just mind blowing.
So I can't wait to
see what you do next.
BILLY RUTLEDGE: Fantastic.
We'll make sure that
you get the kits.
LAURENCE MORONEY:
I'm taking this one.
So thank you so much, Billy.
This has been a real pleasure.
And it's so much fun to
play with this thing.
And I'm hoping many, many,
many, many, many more people
in the future will be getting
hands on and building stuff
and building really
interesting things with it.
BILLY RUTLEDGE: Me too.
Yeah.
More makers, more kits.
We want to see what
people do with it.
LAURENCE MORONEY: Just
keep making awesome stuff.
BILLY RUTLEDGE: For sure.
LAURENCE MORONEY:
So, if you want
to learn how to build one
of these for yourself,
if you want to order the kit,
AIYprojects.withGoogle.com,
it's packed with resources.
There's instructions on how to
build it yourself, of course.
Open source code so that
you can extend the models
in this or there.
The voice models that Billy
mentioned are also in there.
We've put the link in
the description below.
Please go check it out.
I can't wait to see
what you'll make.
Thank you. and
thanks again, Billy.
BILLY RUTLEDGE: Thank you.
[MUSIC PLAYING]